I'm auditioning for the law faculty
comedy show in like 10 minutes what the
law faculty comedy show it's an annual
comedy sketch show written and performed
by law students hey you should audition
with me join buds are self-indulgent
self-centered self-absorbed type-a
personality lawsuits I think that God's
give the comedy no thank you let me
think about it well I'm going if you
change your mind
auditions are okay thank you go I don't
like his pants anyway yeah just go don't
be late see you later
who are you guys just bang already what
does friends man yeah friends can bang
listen I know it's your primitive
impulse turbine minds the concept of a
platonic relationship between a man and
a woman is completely incomprehensible
you might be friends now but you are one
heartbeat away from looking at her
differently and then everything changes
[Music]
what no that's crazy talk it's going to
happen yeah it's a good thing you're not
doing that comedy whatever show spending
weeks together performing most raw
motions sweat tears physical contact
kidding me
interesting I gotta go for class there's
a no more classes it's an extra class
you go Ronny Chang go make it half white
half Asian baby you know happy super
[Music]
hey you came hey what made you change
your mind
you know he knew people get all my
comfort zone please tell me there's not
additional good morning everyone
Ronnie come gather around my name is
Daniel Trembley Burchell and I am
honored to have been chosen as the
youngest director in the illustrious
history of the law faculty comedy show
let's warm up with a quick game of zip
zap zoom so Circle up yes I'm
sorry I'm sorry I I know it was them I
know it was so close it was it's just to
warm up okay moving on well I point to
you I give me your name and your best
impersonation I'm sorry I'm just gonna
need a moment okay you take as long as
you need okay go I'm Henry got one I got
one
come on okay do it just do it don't let
your dreams be dreams yesterday you said
tomorrow so just do it what are you
waiting for do it just do it yes you can
just do it just do it
what was that Shia LeBouf okay
next hi I'm Ronnie and I don't really do
impersonations that character is
hilarious oh right I'm actually not
doing a character and I'm just talking
Ronnie I know you're not doing a
character but that doesn't mean that it
can't be one all right okay funny people
thank you so much for coming ah Asha I
just wanted to say that one of the best
additions I've seen and I wanted to let
you know in person that you're in thank
you so much Jane hey man listen all
right I get it you don't want me to be a
popular thing blah blah whatever I do
wanna be a party anyway I'm offering you
a part in the show oh okay if you think
that I'm petty enough to let our
previous animosity get in the way of art
you've seriously misjudged me sorry you
win yeah okay I guess yeah I can't
believe we both got eaten did I get it
No
so remember what your card was yeah got
your cut
no it wasn't okay dad that's that's a
disappointment a chain just the person I
wanted to see I've got a character that
I think you're gonna be perfect for is a
classic outsider struggling to fit into
a foreign situation is it the angry
Asian laundry man yeah I wrote it
specifically for you okay
hello sir is this the laundromat yes
this is the laundromat can I get this
suit cleaned then it just says say
something angry in Chinese yeah can you
do that yellow saw someone no no that
like much angry you know he is the angry
Asian laundry man after all a James can
you come over here and show Rani how it
might be done sure okay hello sir can I
get this suit cleaned it see gone Ching
you're my yogurt all Niemann gentian jaw
see dog see that scene